en étrange ballet s'est déroulée ce
mardi dans le parc du château de
versailles sous les flocons virevoltant
des fontainiers ont soulevé la statue du
bassin de latone situé au centre de la
composition des jardins pour permettre
sa restauration
de leur côté les jardiniers sont aux
petits soins pour les partenaires
pendant plein travaux on est en train de
poser des voliges en ce moment on a posé
de gazon une petite de petites parties
de gazon samedi mais malheureusement
avec la neige
on le voit pas mais voilà donc là on a
encore deux mois de travail
non je pense qu'on aura fini fin mai
pour présenter au public pour la saison
le nôtre mais on a un peu de travail on
a un petit peu en retard on va dire ce
chantier marque le début de l'hommage
andré le nôtre jardinier du roi louis
xiv
né il ya 400 ans jour pour jour le nôtre
c'est vraiment le l'honnête homme au
sens où l'entendait le xviie siècle
c'est à dire quelqu'un capable de
maîtriser de connaître et pratiquer
toutes les disciplines que ce soit les
mathématiques la géométrie architecture
la peinture le jardin la botanique
l'astronomie et c'est un personnage
complètement éclectique et c'est un
petit peu cet idéal de l'honnête homme
au sens où l'entendait xviie siècle les
manifestations dureront toute l'année le
bosquet du théâtre d'auch détruit en
1775 sera ré interpréter de manière
contemporaine et une exposition de
sculptures d'arbres signée de l'artiste
italien giuseppe penone rythmera les
jardins à partir du 11 juin au printemps
2013 une application mobile permettra
aux visiteurs de se promener dans les
jardins et d'obtenir des informations en
temps réel
rappelons que la touche le nôtre est
présente à saint germain en laye so me
dont saint cloud chantilly ou encore
vaux-le-vicomte mais aussi dans plus de
200 jardins modeste anonyme répertoriés
dans toute la france autant de lieux qui
célèbreront le jardinier du roi soleil